you are not a drop in the ocean
you are the entire ocean
in a drop
raise your words
not your voice
it is rain that grows flowers
not Thunder
there are a thousand ways to understand
your body and soul
listen to these quotes by Rumi and open
up your mind to understand yourself
better
it's your road
and yours alone
Others May walk it with you
but no one can walk it for you
whether one moves slowly or with speed
the one who was a Seeker
will be a finder
the wound is the place where the light
enters you
don't be satisfied with stories
how things have gone with others
unfold your myth
the prophets accept all Agony and trust
it
for the water has never feared the fire
as you start to walk on the way
the way appears
Wherever You Are
and whatever you do
be in love
silence is the language of God
all else's poor translation
sit
be still
and listen
the heart has its own language
the heart knows a hundred thousand ways
to speak
I know you're tired but come
this is the way
[Music]
set your life on fire
seek those who fan Your Flames
you are not meant for crawling
so don't
you have wings
learn to use them and fly
patience is the key to Joy
be an empty page
Untouched by words
the world is a mountain
in which your words are echoed back to
you
be empty of worrying
think of who created thought
wherever you stand
be the soul of that place
when the world pushes you to your knees
you're in the perfect position to pray
love is the bridge between you
and everything
if the light is in your heart
you will find your way home
be soulful
kind
be in love
the only lasting Beauty
is the beauty of the heart
gratitude is the wine for the soul
go on
get drunk
[Music]
all your anxiety is because of your
desire for harmony
seek disharmony
then you will gain peace
what is planted in each person's soul
will sprout
be full of Sorrow that you may become a
hill of joy
weep
that you may break into laughter
let go of your mind
and then be mindful
close your ears and listen
anyone who genuinely and consistently
with both hands looks for something
we'll find it
words our pretext
it is the inner bond that draws one
person to another
not words
you're not your hair
you're not your skin
you're the soul that lives Within
yesterday I was clever
so I wanted to change the world
today I am wise
so I am changing myself
when you see a person who was often
silent and avoids people
try to stay close to him
because he has been given wisdom
everything that is made beautiful and
fair and lovely
is made for the eye of one who sees
there is a life force within your soul
seek that life
there is a gem in the mountain of your
body
seek that mind
old traveler if you are in search of
that don't look outside
look inside yourself and seek that
everyone has been made for some
particular work
and the desire for that work has been
put in every heart
we have collected these quotes by an
Ever famous Persian poet Rumi who said a
lot about our connections with the
universe mind and soul he was titled a
master and after all these years still
stays a master of true wisdom